and I was like no money living in uh one
bedroom with three guys
in New York and my buddy was working at
this place Carmines in New York this
Italian restaurant it's like 11 30 at
night he goes hey Rosie uh he calls me
and he says your hero's here I go I'll
be there I had no money I took a cab
went across town and I waited till they
were done and I just finally went I'm
like hey I just I had to say hello I'm
so sorry to interrupt Miss rossolini big
fan Gary Mr Oldman I'm I'm just a huge
fan
um I'm an actor and um because you're an
actor I said yeah he goes you want to
work with me so yeah he goes he grabs my
hand and he gives this long beaten looks
in my eyes and goes you will
wow